so I have three different relationships
here between x and y and i want to think
about which of these if any are
proportional relationships and then i
want to graph them to see if we can see
anything visually that makes them
obviously proportional and just as a
reminder a proportional relationship is
one where the ratio between the two
variables and let's say we took the
ratio between y and x you could also go
the other way around the ratio between x
and y but the ratio between y and x is
always going to be some number some
constant number or you could rewrite it
another way if you were to multiply both
sides of this equation times X you could
say put in a proportional relationship Y
is always going to be equal to some
constant times X so with that out of the
way let's look at these three
relationships so this one over here let
me do another column here another
another column this is let me call this
the Y over X column I'm just going to
keep figuring out what this ratio is for
each of these pairs so for this first
pair when when X is 1 Y is 1/2 so this
ratio is 1/2 over 1 well 1/2 over 1 is
just the same thing as 1/2 when X is 4 y
is 2 this ratio is going to be 2 over 4
which is the same thing as 1/2 when X is
negative 2 and Y is negative 1 this
ratio is negative 1 over negative 2
which is the same thing as 1/2 so for at
least these 3 points that we sampled
from this relationship it looks like the
ratio between y and X is always 1/2 in
this case K would be 1/2 we could write
Y over X is always equal to 1/2 or at
least for these 3 points that we sampled
and we'll say well maybe it's always the
case for this relationship between x and
y or if you want to write it another way
you could write that Y is equal to 1/2 X
now let's graph this thing well when X
is 1 Y is 1/2 when X is 4 y is 2 when X
is negative 2 y is negative 1 I didn't
put the marker for negative 1 would be
but right about there and so if we say
these three points are sampled on the
entire relationship and the entire
relationship is y is equal to 1/2 X well
the the point the line that represents
or
the set of all points that would
represent the the possible XY pairs it
would be a line it would be a line that
goes through the origin because look if
x is 0 1/2 times 0 is going to be equal
to Y and so let's think about some of
the key characteristics one it is a line
this is this is a line here it is a
linear relationship and it also goes
through the origin and it makes sense
that it goes through an origin because
if in a proportional relationship
actually when you look over here is 0
over 0 that's indeterminate form and
then that gets a little bit strange but
when you look at this right over here
well if X is 0 and you multiply it by
some constant Y is going to need to be 0
as well so for any proportional
relationship if you're including when x
equals 0 then Y would need to be equal
to 0 as well and also if you were to if
you were to plot its graph it would be a
line that goes through the origin it
would be a line that goes through the
origin and so this is a proportional
relationship and it it's graph is
represented by a line that goes through
the origin now let's look at this one
over here this one in blue so let's
think about whether it is proportional
and we could do the same test by
calculating the ratio between y and X Y
and X so it's going to be C for this
first one is going to be 3 over 1 which
is just 3 that's going to be 5 over 2 5
over 2 well 5 over 2 is not the same
thing as 3 so already we know that this
is not proportional not not proportional
this is not a we don't have to look we
don't even have to look at this Third
Point right over here where if we took
the ratio between y and X it's negative
1 over negative 1 which would just be 1
well let's see let's graph this just for
fun and see what it looks like when X is
1 Y is 3 when X is 1 Y is 3 when X is 2
y is 5 X is 2 y is 5 and when X is
negative 1 Y is negative 1 when X is
negative 1 Y is negative
I forgot to put the hash mark right
there I was wearing it right around
there and so if we said okay let's just
give the benefit of doubt that maybe
this is a these are three points from a
line because it looks like I can
actually connect them with a line then
the line would look something like this
the line would look something like the
line would look something like this so
notice this is linear this is a line
right over here but it does not go
through the origin so if you're just
looking at a relationship visually
linear is good but it needs to go
through the origin as well for it to be
proportional relationship and you see
that right here this is a linear
relationship or at least these three
pairs could be sampled from a linear
relationship but that but it does the
graph does not go through the origin and
we see here when we looked at the ratio
that it wasn't indeed not proportional
so this is not proportional now let's
look at this one over here let's let's
look let's look at what we have here so
I'll look at the ratios Y over X so for
this first pair 1 over 1 then we have 4
over 2 well we immediately see that we
are not proportional and then 9 over 3
would be 3 so clearly this this is not a
constant number here we don't always
have the same value here so this is also
not not proportional not proportional
but let's graph it just for fun when X
is 1 Y is 1 when X is 2 y is 4 this
looks actually looks like the graph of
this looks like the graph of y is equal
to x squared when X is 3 y is 9 at least
these three points are consistent with
it so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so it's going to
look something and so if this really is
if these points are sampled from y
equals x squared then when x is 0 Y
would be 0 so this one actually would go
through the origin but notice it's not a
line it's not a linear relationship this
right over here is the graph of y equals
x squared so this one also is not
proportional so once again these three
points could be sampled from y equals
1/2 x
these three points these three points
could be sampled from let's see why is
equal to let's see it looks like a line
when this looks like it could be y is
equal to 2x plus one so it's a linear
relationship but it does not go through
the origin so it's not proportional and
this these three points looks like it
could be look like they could be sampled
from y equals x squared which goes
through the origin when X is zero Y is
zero but it's not a linear relationship
but anyway you look at it if you look at
it visually it has to be a line that
goes through the origin or if you look
at a table of values you just look at
the ratios and the ratios always have to
be the same value and that was only the
case with this magenta one right over
here